fancy a coffee in a brussels cafe these
days and you'll need to provide some
information first
proof you've been vaccinated against
kovid no proof no table indoors the
belgian capital is the latest part of
europe to introduce covid safety passes
for restaurants pubs gyms and other
venues an inconvenience some say but
necessary
i feel more safe so it's fine it's fine
for me to show my covertas it has some
pros that has some cons
but for me personally it's been more of
an inconvenience than a help
it's very intrusive at some point like
to get asked
if you're totally vaccinated
to have like an id to have all your
medical records exposed that way
it's hard to spot anyone not wearing a
mask on public transport here face
coverings also required if these
passengers visit the shops most eu
nations from belgium to france and
germany keeping or increasing measures
to fight covid which experts say helps
explain in part why the number of cases
is rising more slowly in the eu than the
uk
england uk but definitely england was
earlier to drop most of the measures you
had the freedom day in july this was a
time when we still had some restrictions
it was more a gradual process in belgium
so it gradually started lifting all
measures but now we're at the point most
of them have been lifted which is also
not good because october november are
terribly difficult months italy now
requires workers to show so-called green
passes with proof of vaccination or pay
for regular covid tests themselves
measures which provoked anger and
protest in several areas but the logic
is if you can't work or dine out without
a pass you're more likely to get jabbed
an eu leaders attending a summit in
brussels insisted mass vaccination is
still the answer we are still in a
covert situation which is which is not
over and the only way out is vaccine
vaccine vaccine vaccines but some
experts warn kovid passes could lead to
complacency with people thinking if
people around them have been jabbed
there's no need for other precautions
like mars wearing their message is
vaccinated people can still get and
spread covid michelle clifford sky news
brussels